because do you do a lot of like Japanese
events at all in like tons of promotions
because I know you go to like a lot of
American conventions you're at ax last
year right yeah do you do the same kind
of like promotion on the Japanese side
of things as well uh yes I'm responsible
for all that okay for orange side okay
so we work with a production committee
side to get that done I've always
wondered when when anime Studios go to
like an anime convention is it purely
just for promotion like what what are
they normally kind of like what is the
point of strip clubs and strip clubs
research actually thank you very much is
it like is everyone's curious if you're
a voice actor so you go to it you know
you can sign something you can make some
money but like I assume for Studios it's
there's got to be something else because
like you know pretty conventions aren't
that profitable I imagine so for my my
my objective is actually uh inspiration
oh okay because
um so for meeting their fans I mean
Japan there's not too many events that
you can meet your fans that's true right
so I mean if you're a directory by me if
your character is not in mind me but if
your anime later you don't mind not meet
your fans right so I want people to more
meet their fans and who are they so
where do they come from where are they
going is the question I always ask too
yeah so are you from this area are you
from other yeah did you travel here
right those kind of things really matter
too then also the culture so by going to
that location I mean feel that culture
yeah I mean that really matters we're
anime is a global medium so it really
matters that you get inspired by so many
things do you feel like there's been
more of uh Spotlight put on like the
international audience in the time
you've been working in the anime
industry yeah well I mean the business
has heavily skewed through the
international oh really so I wish more
Stu more companies will focus a lot more
on the on the global
um strategy do you feel like that's only
going to grow like the the focus on the
international side I feel like it has to
well because I remember you did an
interview
yeah and the guy was like I don't even
know we had an international audience I
think he was also jokes
he was like I don't know yeah in a rare
display of Japanese facilities he was
actually just being facetious
no it was funny you say that because so
many people in the comments of that
video said the same thing they thought
he was being 100 serious but no he was
just joking yeah like I think they have
I think they're fully aware that yes a
big majority of their like audience is
international and like you know they're
not gonna necessarily like pertain to
that audience a hundred percent
obviously right because you know
domestic is the first priority but like
I think at this point with how much
anime has grown I I think it's pretty
hard to avoid well yeah there's always
that that good that um conversation that
goes on online about how people are like
no they they only make anime for for
Japan they don't they don't care about
other countries and and when they're
making it but I suppose if it's heavily
skewed for a international market that I
I mean that argument doesn't really hold
any water yeah I think I think there's
still like I don't know you can confirm
with this but like I guess like they
still they do care about the
international audience but I guess it's
not like first priority for a lot of
students videos right I mean I think
it's more that a lot of the workforce
won't understand of course yeah I mean
they could say they're in San Diego look
at marketing data and say oh we
understand it but they don't understand
because they're never from there right
America
decades on both sides
everyone just just maybe have a tour
into America for California yeah yeah so
I guess that's like a reason why you
send these uh like stuff to like be more
experienced more inspiring never thought
about it yeah I'm trying to get away
from I feel like I'm in America all the
time yeah I need to stop listening to
America but I guess yeah from a Japanese
perspective right you wouldn't
inherently get a lot of experience with
foreign countries and and I suppose
getting more in tune with the global
world is I mean it's you know it's
extremely Fresh So traveling uh some
people know it might not even travel on
our team so there's a lot of people
working at home yeah yeah are they
always like other Japanese staff members
always shocked or surprised when they
see like the international found
reaction when they go to a convention
like Anime Expo or you just want to
sakura con as well right so we just
started sending people to because Kobe
we couldn't do it yeah and I joined five
years ago so I want that's the goal I
want to do but now that we have Trigon
Stampede we're doing the tour so I mean
director and my other partner producer
was able to experience so next month I'm
taking my animators to another con right
so I want to keep on doing this to make
sure that our team are more rich and
experienced okay yeah that's such a cool
way of looking at it yeah very cool just
get back to animating what are you doing
I mean
it's like all right we've taken you to
the strip club back to animating come on
you're telling me the secret to Studio
orange if that's what they want I might
consider
I've not come from
the bachelor's team of Japanese
animators in like the dingiest grossest
strip club in like Ohio
in Vancouver my director wanted to go to
this street that's very looks I'm like I
can't not walk in that street
I look like a tourist
I'm a jacket by my side
my both my hands are tied up I can't
walk in that street
okay give me a moment I put my backbone
zip it up zip it up yeah and like put my
hands on I'm like okay
I was ready
so like so you're saying the secret to
Studio orange is your staff members
touch grass that is
holy [__] going outside is the secret
this entire
time God damn basement dwellers who are
like hoping to join the anime Community
you're like no no like this this is not
what I wanted
where'd you take your staff members if
you want to show them your like American
Ninja
where'd you take them where'd you take
them I mean every city is different so I
mean right I would love to take every
single city
um what's your favorite City my favorite
City well I mean I grew up in La so I I
was seeing eleva until I went to Seattle
Seattle
you want them to have like a
quintessential American experience
you're like let's go to the gun range
let's go to Denny's a real Denny's let's
go to IHOP let's just have like this is
let's just go full American yeah oh my
God that is the culture shock experience
for them they should do it
you just like see the calories
I mean if it creates culture shock they
should go to yoshinoa in America oh it's
totally different
it was a culture shock to my system I
think my body fought back because I had
the McDonald's in America I was like
this can't be it wow how I just love to
imagine Japanese people going to
McDonald's in the US being like wait
it's gross the biggest culture show in
terms of like uh when I came to Japan
was that the KFC didn't have gravy I was
like that's that just doesn't seem right
yeah that feels like a fundamental mess
up and the court saw is not sweet yeah
yeah it's like lettuce and carrots
doesn't have gravy I feel like that's
like that's everything that's like
McDonald's
you know what I mean it's like what with
us the court sir
[Music]
I I agree I agree I agree I agree which
is rare for me it's very rare what is
someone like the biggest culture shocks
that your staff members have gone
through I mean go into that shady place
was one thing last weekend oh that was
last weekend
I mean they just come back
to Japanese food too when they've been
to California it's like the homelessness
they're always like oh my God like this
is insane the Vancouver's part was
really into more than that I think it
was pretty bad too hey there was a guy
with butt naked right there
I mean yesterday he was about Monday kid
too oh God no I think when I was there
it was too cold to do that
extremities would have been frozen off
if you did that I reckon knows those
cheeks it's the same guy it's the same
it's the same butt naked guy every day
so when you since since you're from La
where do you know you take where'd you
normally take people to show them to
show the Mellow
skid row no it's got to be right I mean
when I used to
um staff at MX for my radio turned on
once and like the one volunteer was
Japanese he wasn't from local right like
I'm in a place called uh Compton
[Music]
it's unfortunate that I think now uh in
L.A like Skid Row is right next to Tokyo
Little Tokyo oh and so yeah a lot of the
time during the convention people end up
around that part it's like no don't
don't go there yeah but right away and
don't walk around too much and it's nice
to the Art District as well yeah yeah
sandwich between
I mean naito loves American toys so we
went to uh frankincense uh there's a
place called frankincense where all
these um toy sellers Gather in this in
the storage garage like a small con
right there like like a flea market type
yeah oh okay I wanna I wanna see Storage
Wars Storage Wars Japan version now
that's on my mind I just thought about
that
I mean they weren't hopping because no
one owns a storage unit yeah dude
there's loads of storage units in Japan
but I don't think they auction them off
there when they're no no no people just
use them man yeah well they just
demolish everything when they pay the
bills or something yes
Repo Man comes in takes everything
probably yeah so uh what's like the F
what's like the final goal of CD orange
what what what
is like what are you guys working
towards in terms of your studio world
domination oh hell yeah
let's go
I like to hear
how a lot of the animators you know
initially wanted to get into gaming is
there a potentially see Studio Orange
game or something along those lines I
mean for struggling I definitely want to
do some kind of game and yeah
so we'll see what comes through that'd
be so sick what about video game
adaptations
um that's definitely something I mean
one of the projects that we always talk
about too oh hell yeah is there like one
video game you really want to see being
turned into an anime regardless of if
it's like done by orange or not yeah
that you think would be like unless
you're working on it unless you're
working on it now
on the roll
it could be like a personal pick as well
but it's been so long since I played a
lot of video games I always say I want I
want Doom to be tuned into an anime
somehow no no no I don't want to work on
dude
yeah because you know that Doom is great
as it is but I wanna I want it to be
crazy
I think like uh I think like a dark
souls could work I mean it's already
inspired from the likes of Berserk
anyway right so it already has that kind
of it it passes the vibe check of
potential anime yeah I mean when I
always think about adapting anime what
kind of new values can I bring to that
Community right right so like
um my recent game I was already gone
into other ring oh I spent 300 hours in
that world just mesmerized by every
single I'm jumping against the walls
these guys still haven't played it yet
you should yeah I know
you're only the 5 000th person who's
told us that everyone Elton ring is
amazing because I'm just not prepared to
give up two weeks of my life as one
month
has allowed you to have the experience
of like hearing operatic music with a
giant sword slamming down on some
monster and seeing it Buckle that's so
cool everything's so cool do you think a
Guilty Gear would be a good anime even
though that's already kind of like anime
S I mean they make their own anime too
so yeah I mean I mean those are things I
never imagined really right so so you
think that because it's so close to
anime already that there's no let's say
value in getting like a an anime
adaptation I mean it's it's more about
my own imagination so yeah if I can
imagine there's a new value to that so I
just don't have that piece to consider
so if their team is like oh this will be
amazing combination I'm like oh I mean
like I could be amazed by that so yeah
I'm curious did you want did you watch
alkane yes what did you think of that as
an industry you know an industry veteran
that works in 3D animation because
watching Arcane that that blew my mind
away in terms of what they were doing
with their animation like like
do you think
do you think Studio orange is or could
get to that level so I um as of the
creativeness of our CEO right we can I
believe right but we are not ready to um
that could be money or system or the
amount of people we have yeah we are not
ready but one day I'm going to get to
that magnitude this is definitely
something I swore when I saw hurricane
because such amazing it's so good it's
such a catchy song too
it's in my head all the time
in season two I think got announced
recently yeah
in some in terms of like animation
outside of Japanese anime is there any
other shows or movies like Arcane uh
that you guys get inspired by because
I'm curious because you know aside from
aside from Arcane there was like into
the spite of us recently which was very
very impressive and then there's the
upcoming Scott Pilgrim anime right yeah
yeah and uh Puss in Boots too which I've
referred to as so good which I've heard
was incredible do you guys ever draw a
reference from like American animation
at all um as a studio level we not
really um individual level definitely
Everyone's Watching so many things right
um like for example our CEO wants to if
even possible he wants to do Tom and
Jerry one day so that's something
completely different style from what we
do right now right but we see that if he
used to do it we were able to do
something amazing right right because
like because I I think like one thing is
like technology is always evolving as
we've uh as we've already discussed I
was wondering how much you guys put
focus in just the general technology of
like what other studios are using and
doing in terms of just the animation uh
animation process in general
or is it all kind of like in-house kind
of thing
is I mean a lot of the technology we
development is in-house whenever the
technology is available on the market we
try to test it and see how we can
Implement as our own right right
um but in a sense um a lot of the
management is done outside of Japan so
that's why we've heard a lot to the
other studios in Japan right okay okay
do you guys ever think you're gonna do a
Mecca I want to see Stevie orange tackle
I mean we came from America so and our
animators love Mecca
so look forward to it is there a single
animator that doesn't like makeup yeah I
feel like I feel like that's the
Baseline criteria to be an animator it's
like do you like giant robots fighting
you can be an animator yeah
so go ahead yeah we haven't had I mean
Gundams going on right now the other
Mecca has been absent for a while so
yeah amazing to have a I mean I feel
like gundam's always Gundam has always
been like the strong IP that will go
through the end of anime yeah it's kind
of like the Evergreen Mega right yeah
it's just like no matter what period
there's always going to be a fan base
for it yeah yeah exactly no I would love
to see Studio orange Taco
hopefully hopefully in the future
because